in today's video we'll cover all of
ichigo's forms in Bleach we'll start
with his regular form but in later parts
of the video we'll explain some of these
most powerful legendary forms in his
human form Ichigo is incredibly strong
for a high schooler ever since Ichigo
was a child he used to go to a dojo to
train with tatsuki although Ichigo
wasn't as strong back then and used to
lose a lot he changed after his mother's
death and became very strong since then
he has repeatedly shown great agility
and coordination in his attacks what's
really impressive is that Ichigo is also
very courageous and doesn't care for the
number of enemies he has to fight to
protect his friends Ichigo stopped
training for a short time but the
constant attacks from bullies and his
father kept his skills fresh although
this is ichigo's weakest form his
natural talent and hard work will lead
him to becoming much stronger in the
future Shinigami form Ichigo obtains his
Shinigami powers for the first time when
his family is in great danger of a
hollow attack at that time an injured
rookia could no longer fight so she gave
Ichigo her powers to defeat the hollow
floor surprisingly a complete novice
like ijigo managed to defeat a massive
Hollow effortlessly which even a skilled
Shinigami like Rukia had trouble
fighting when Awakening his Shinigami
Powers Ichigo also obtains his zambak
though a soul-cutter sword the base form
of zompoc though is the same for all
shinigamis but what makes a difference
are the powers obtained in the shikai
and the Bankai forms the borrowed power
allowed Ichigo to fight alongside Rukia
and his friends who also unlocked their
abilities due to the hogyoku inside
Rukia however even with his natural
talent and Newfound Powers Ichigo wasn't
Untouchable in this form therefore he
suffered his first serious defeat
against renji and byakya who came to the
human world to take Rukia back and
punish her for staying in the human
world for too long I also heard these
guys punish people who don't hit the
Subscribe button so make sure to click
it just to be safe anyway after the
fight yakiya took the borrowed Powers
leaving Ichigo completely powerless
however with kisuke's help Ichigo
obtains his own shingami powers and
finds out the name of his zompakto
Ichigo uses this form most of the time
especially in the soul Society Arc his
newly obtained powers paid off as his
rematch against ranji went exceptionally
well the last time the two met renji had
easily beaten him even with his powers
restricted this time however the tables
had turned and Ichigo defeated renji who
fought against him with everything he
had what truly showcased his strength
was the battle against the captain of
the 11th division kempachi Zaraki who's
well known for being a beast in combat
Ichigo has one of the most thrilling
fights of the series with Zaraki and
pushes him to remove his eye patch which
was limiting his powers the guy defeated
a captain despite being an amateur
Shinigami who didn't even know how to
control his own spiritual power around
this time ichigo's strength had
increased even more from battling strong
foes in the soul Society moreover his
speed significantly increased as well
which even impressed byakya who's well
known for his flash step however byakia
is a formidable Foe and can't be taken
down that easily therefore yoroichi
trained Ichigo to obtain a much stronger
state of his impact toe so that he could
have a chance against the captain of the
sixth division Bankai form with all the
captains of the Soul Society on his back
Ichigo had to gain more power to save
Rukia but he had no time to waste so
Ichigo obtains a new form Bankai through
special training with yoruichi it's
important to note that only captains and
Powerful lieutenants have Bankai which
cannot be obtained easily what's more it
takes over 10 years of practice to
completely Master this form and use it
properly as our main character didn't
really have 10 years he fights on Getsu
physically for two and a half days and
manages to achieve his Bankai this power
did wonders for Ichigo as a zombato's
size decreased increasing his speed and
destructive power it proved to be a game
changer in the fight with byakia as he
managed to actually see the akea's flash
step in effortlessly Dodges attack as
well what's more Ichigo started using a
strong attack called getsugatinsho which
gave him an edge in the battle however
it would be highly unrealistic for
Ichigo to defeat a captain of byakiya's
level when he was just a novice and he
realizes this pretty soon this
eventually leads him to awaken an even
more powerful form Hollow form unable to
move his body and being repeatedly cut
instead by biyakia Ichigo is on his
knees and almost about to die however
just as byakia is about to land the
final blow ichigo's qualification begins
during this period Ichigo has no control
over his hello self and the power he
showcases is immense and chaotic making
him faster stronger and more Reckless
than before his powers completely
changed the course of the fight pushing
byakiya to go on the defensive after the
hollow form severely damages yakia ichio
manages to retake his Consciousness by
breaking the mask and proceeds to fight
with his Bankai eventually winning the
fight later in the series Ichigo forms a
companionship with ex-soul Society
captains and lieutenants who were
hullified by Eisen and are known as
visards the visards then help him tame
his inner Hollow through tough training
by making him enter his inner World in
there he had to fight Hollow Ichigo to
access the powers as he pleases and
remain conscious while using them while
Ichigo is fighting his inner Hollow
visor fought unconscious Ichigo in the
real world while he was fully hullified
after retaking his Consciousness Ichigo
stopped his holified self and broke the
mask Ichigo could use the mask for only
four seconds at a time and after
training with the visors his limit
increased to 11 seconds however his
growth didn't stop there as the time
limit of his mask further increases
during his third rematch with the sixth
Espada Grim jaw jaggerjacks here we see
Ichigo using the mask for an extended
period of time in order to fight on
equal grounds with grimjaw's second form
vasto Lorde for him during ichigo's
fight with the fourth aspada okiora
Cipher he realizes the massive
difference in their powers and couldn't
do much against him on the brink of
death Ichigo is lying on the floor after
ukiora shoots Acero oscaris through his
chest that even Orihime couldn't heal
everyone thought that Ichigo died at
that time however as Orihime begins to
cry ichio pushes himself and his inner
Hollow takes over again but this time
with a massive change in his appearance
Ichigo becomes a vasto Lorde having long
straight hair all the way down to his
waist what confirms that he's a hollow
now is the hole in his chest which he
didn't have any of the pre previous
times he hallified the scariest part of
this transformation is his Hollow mask
that covers the entirety of his face
looking like a skull with big menacing
horns this form of Ichigo is entirely
mindless and chaotic with the only goal
of crushing everything in front of him
both friends and foes vasto Lorde Ichigo
has new very powerful abilities one of
them being assetto which can cause
widespread destruction he also gained
immense strength allowing him to destroy
a significant portion of Los noches with
just one swing of his Blade the guy
easily tore off ukiora's arm in the
blink of an eye this alone should be
enough for everyone to realize just how
powerful he really is now furthermore
Ichigo also demonstrates several more
abilities like Fast regeneration and
sunido a high-speed movement technique
utilized by Hollows and orenkar moreover
he almost killed udyu but okiora broke
his horn which reverted ichio back into
his normal State although he never
utilized this form again some of the
forms will soon cover are even more
powerful than this one dungai form next
is Ichigo those dangai form which he
obtains after witnessing just how
inferior he is to Eisen at that time
Ichigo gave up to despair losing hope to
fight due to the massive difference in
power however ichimaru and ichigo's
father saw his potential therefore
iching takes him to dungai a
corridor-like dimension connecting the
soul Society in the human world time
flows faster in Danga compared to the
outside world so ishin teaches Ichigo
the final gatsuka 10 show in under 3
months which will help him greatly in
defeating Eisen afterwards each go
rejoins the battle with a completely new
appearance now much taller and with his
hair grown in this state it appears that
Ichigo has his Bankai released but the
difference now is that getsuga is also
merged with him ichigo's spiritual power
was so strong that even Eisen couldn't
sense it the donkey form considerably
increased ichigo's speed and power
allowing him to battleyze him without
even getting a scratch what's more
Ichigo even returned the favor by easily
catching eisen's sword much like he did
ichigo's back in the soul Society Arc
the guy really made eyes and delusional
making him think that all the
destruction around them was his power
but in reality it was all ichigo's doing
although Eisen continued to grow due to
the hogyoku in his body Ichigo still
managed to slice him in his fourth
fusion and easily blocked his attacks
final gets a good 10 show to put an end
to Eisen once and for all Ichigo uses
the final getsuga 10 show form in this
state Ichigo becomes gatsuga himself
meaning he uses the entirety of his soul
as a source of spiritual power for one
significant attack Ichigo explains that
if he uses this technique he loses all
his abilities as a Shinigami making it
the final gatsuka 10 show Ichigo learned
this ability in his inner World while
fighting zangetsu for three months
zangetsu was entirely against teaching
Ichigo this last technique because he
wanted to protect him from the dire
consequences of the method eventually
Ichigo convinces him leading zongetsu to
stab Ichigo with the blade telling him
that by accepting his sword he will
acquire the final gezigaten show in the
end Ichigo had to resort to using this
technique because Eisen became Immortal
and would regenerate incredibly fast
which meant that he had to go all out
and quickly end him ichigo's appearance
changes as his hair grows longer and
turns black giving him a very mysterious
yet terrifying look Ichigo swings
towards Eisen doing so causes a massive
veil of black spiritual power to erupt
upwards and approach the target heavily
damaging anything caught within the
blast the technique is strong enough to
severely damage Eisen forcing him to use
his weaker transformation after this
attack the black spiritual power
disappears as Ichigo falls to the ground
in severe pain losing his Shinigami
Powers but in the end this form had
weakened Eisen enough to allow urahara
to seal him away there were only three
forms left to cover and trust me you
definitely won't want to miss these full
ring form after losing his powers as a
result of his previous transformation
Ichigo finds out that becoming a
full-bringer would help him become a
Shinigami again fullbringers are
spiritually aware humans born with the
eponymous ability fullbring which allows
them to manipulate the souls that reside
in all physical matter this power is
awakened in children whose mothers were
attacked by Hollows and since ichigo's
mother falls into that group Ichigo
gains access to full brain powers in
this form he Ichigo becomes much faster
and also gains the ability to jump high
into the air which greatly helps him in
his fights in addition fullbring Ichigo
can generate swirling blasts of
spiritual power comparable to gatsuka 10
show in appearance maybe even in strain
Ichigo eventually regained his Shinigami
Powers after being stabbed in the back
by Rukia with a special sword containing
spiritual energies given by all of the
captains and lieutenants before we cover
ichigo's most powerful form in the
entire show let's first quickly cover
his Shinigami rebuild form during the
Thousand Years blood War Arc Ichigo
fails to defeat yiwatch and undergoes
training in the Royal Palace in
preparation for the war there nichigo
discovered that he also had Quincy's
Powers ichigo's father ishin is the
reason for his inheritance of Shinigami
energy while his mother masaki is
responsible for both his inherited
Quincy and Hollow Powers after mastering
zongetsu Ichigo is transformed into a
new and Powerful Shinigami form with two
zompaktos one representing the hollow
form looking like his old blade and the
other his spiritual Shinigami which is
smaller after reclaiming his powers he
also got improved versions of his
attacks now he can release an
exceptionally powerful gatsuga 10 show
with his knife-like sword and giant
shock waves with the other one
additionally he gains a new attack as he
combines the two blades releasing an
attack named gets a good juji Shoal
Bankai rebuild Ichigo achieves this
state by placing his swords together in
a specific way in this form the outer
section of the blade turns white with
the addition of a chain connecting the
hilt in the edge of the blade in short
Ichigo combines all his power and
obtains the ultimate form Beyond
holification which even you Havoc
noticed unlike his vasto Lorde form he
was completely conscious assuring scared
Orihime that it really was him in not a
Mindless creature thirsting for blood
Ichigo then explains how his mothers and
Father's Powers were constantly at odds
with each other but now they finally
have found balance his appearance
changed again making him look like a
mixture of his vasto Lorde and Shinigami
forms with the giant white horn on his
head the Bankai rebuild gave him great
speed and strength allowing Ichigo to
pose a threat to yuhavak even making him
draw his blades out although though
Ichigo managed to perform a very
powerful attack by combining his getsuga
10 show with Grande Cerro in the end it
was easily blocked by yuhavak he then
proceeded to break ichigo's Bankai and
overpower him rather easily however
after yuhavak leaves to destroy the soul
Society Ichigo zangetsu is fully
restored with the help of tsukushima
with his book at the end and Orihime
soten kishun in the end with the help of
Eisen and uriu Ichigo swings his blade
one last time and finally defeats the
father of Quincy